foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everybody this is the daily
nerdy news show keeping you updated on
what you want to be talking about right
now live from New rockstars actual break
room we're so happy to be with you here
on this lovely Thursday coming up today
into the spider-verse goes live action
this is this is late breaking news we're
really excited to talk about this Amy
Adams talking about Lois Lane
potentially maybe if you forgot she was
Lois Lane yes and remember that smile
she gives when when like Clark's in the
room and she's like the horniest smile
ever she's like movie
I think I think she gets in a soaking
tub in every movie yeah yeah
no you're right
uh and of course we're going to be
talking about there was a great
interview with Marvel producer Nate
Moore I put a gap there to make sure I
don't accidentally say Namor
um where he gave some kind of Insider
info on the upcoming armor Wars film
that we're really excited about and so
we're gonna be uh diving deep on that uh
but first joining me today thrilled to
have Brandon Barrick hello
Jessica Clements hello Tommy Bechtel hi
no
never again all right hello also our
colors our colors again look at us I'm a
peppermint boy today you look like an
Andy's mint ah thanks Kohl's for making
the same flannel in 19 different colors
it's flannel season on the break room
what do I wear tomorrow
flannel nothing but a smile uh speaking
of tomorrow or today today do we have a
Redemption for you I'll take it from
here Zack daddy if you don't mind it's
the break room book club inaugural
edition let's face facts we're heading
into Thanksgiving and Christmas and for
most of you I assume that's a depressing
time of year your trash bins are
freezing and frosting over your your
your your hot meals are gonna get cold
real quick as they're as the uh Baja
Fresh throws tortillas at you into the
dumpster at the end of every evening
you need a little hope in your life is
what I'm saying and this is crazy
uh we have scoured the bookshelves in
the self-help section for some pretty
incredible self-help books what's going
on here I I did one sip I didn't want
the iciest no I did
it was one sip
I know one sip could sink a ship all
right listen to me listen you guys are
all trash let's focus up what's going on
here chat reviewers are all garbage got
it okay
we'd scoured the self-help section of
the bookstore we found some great books
self-help books training manuals advice
guides from MCU characters for every
fifty dollars that you pull out of your
meager pockets and send in a Super Chat
we will give you the breakdown we'll
present our book club one of those books
for you now here's where it gets really
special we all know Zach won in a
landslide in his tattoo competition uh
the competition to get Gucci to moochie
tattooed on him and I'm frankly thrilled
about that
however we all agree that kind of the
best Marvel movies are team-ups right
and I felt like I wanted to be a good
teammate to Zach so if you jabroni's
manage to raise 300 duckles doublets
whatever coins cash Super Chat
I'll get a tattoo too
and I'm gonna get it on a very
surprising place and again these are ink
box tattoos inbox one of the spots the
tattoos look amazing and in fact if they
hadn't looked so good I would have never
agreed to this the uh the tattoos are
temporary The Morbid time is forever
okay uh but let's get into our headlines
okay and again we're leading with uh
yesterday Matt Bellini who makes a great
podcast called the town that's all about
Hollywood Insider information he had an
interview with Nate Moore Kevin feige's
right-hand man over there uh at Marvel
uh and they talked about all kinds of
stuff the creative process at Marvel how
they develop new new projects how they
hire directors and writers all kinds of
great stuff some of which we might cover
but he dropped a little nugget about an
upcoming property we were really
interested in you started talking about
armor Wars which was originally slated
to be a Disney plus series uh but the
decision it was made earlier this year
to flip that over to becoming a film yes
and he kind of went into detail about
why that decision was made and we
thought that was really interesting yeah
definitely very fascinating the thing I
think you and I were talking about the
most interesting thing to me is that
it's not someone coming to Marvel with
their own idea for a series or a movie
Marvel has these ideas the executives
get together whether they said they said
it's that yearly or sometimes uh every
two year Retreat where they they
basically build the pitch right and then
they find someone to Shepherd that
project whereas I always thought it was
like these auteurs these like flavor of
the month directors and producers and
writers coming to Marvel and being like
hear me out
Hulk but a lady
yeah yeah basically they have a shelf of
like projects they want to make oh Ryan
coogler oh taika ytt oh Chloe Zhao right
like anything's on this shelf kind of
speak to you right and then they they
find their pairings that way uh with
armor Wars right like he went into
detail they had you know the Shelf
packet for armor Wars they started
looking at it and they were like what
makes this great oh man to do this we
need a big budget yeah and like the
Disney plus series though they are
extremely expensive Series right like
much lower budget than the Marvel films
of course
um so like that's interesting oh big
budget armor Wars what what does that
mean for this idea right
um and uh one of the most interesting
things he said is that they want to
leverage the ideas of that movie armor
Wars and affect other movies down the
line yeah so like I don't know I
personally when it was a series I was
like oh this would be a little offshoot
this is roadie gone off maybe not on
some Stark techy stuff or whatever but
like oh it's gonna have a bigger impact
on the MCU I like that I mean I don't
think that necessarily means that our
our Disney Plus shows are less important
I think it just means the storytelling
is a little different right like and it
kind of I think in my opinion the
listening to that podcast shaped my
brain the way I all think about
predictions for things of like yeah
maybe these TV shows are more about
introducing the characters than they are
about pushing a storyline along or
introducing a new conflict maybe it's
more about it's like opening up an
action figure for the first time it's
like you get this play with iron heart
you get to play with Moon Knight I know
it's a weird example I had a lot of
dolls as a child and an adult they're
not dolls they're action figures Mom
they're my guys I used to call them my
guys my guys uh guys in the chat yeah
you guys but I think you know we we
often get cut up and we love predicting
things and speculating but like oh what
are the 19 cameos that'll be in She-Hulk
or whatever what are the oh how will
Tony Stark come back to life in Moon
night or whatever right and his
statements kind of affirmed that like oh
they're probably Gonna Save the really
big moments the Crossovers the big
cameos for the movies do you think
roady's sad for it to be going from a
series to a movie not at all no I feel
like they because I genuinely wanted I
feel like bigger celebrities like him
are always like uh what was Star Wars um
uh no well it happened yeah okay I'll
just say
he was like I don't want I want to save
myself for the Silver Screen I don't
want to be on uh Liam Neeson yes he was
like I don't want to be on the show so I
make sense but then I'm also like what
makes me nervous is because we were
talking about Roadies contract being
also completely done are they just like
let's make this is also farewell like
let's like let's make a lot let's put a
lot into this let's make it into a movie
because it's also going to be his
goodbye and I don't want that okay okay
I don't want it to be as goodbye either
but I will say
those Iron Man suits the Stark
technology designs they got to spend a
lot of money to make them look really
realistic and good and it's like kind of
like dragons and Game of Thrones it's
like less is sometimes more but I don't
think you could do armor Wars where
you're sparingly showing the armor and
the war right I think it needs to be a
lot of armor yeah
I when I was thinking about that I was
like oh maybe that's why they just want
to go to the movies because it's more
money more budget but I'm like you guys
had to like change She-Hulk back and
forth so often that I'd assume that your
budget for She-Hulk was also still
pretty big sure yeah well you know those
budgets are huge and yeah they're so
very expensive series to make relative
to Television right but television is
such a lower bracket what does make me
think like wasn't this announcement made
around the release of She-Hulk oh you
think they changed their minds it is
hard to do a heavy CGI Series right even
think about Moon night how much of that
was practical right like versus like you
know exciting too because yeah instead
of a nine episode series where there's
maybe some armor warring happen in two
of the episodes right that's like a
movie they can have in a bunch I also
like this conversation he has it's a
great podcast uh because it makes me
think that maybe Marvel is seeing now
that our movies and our TV series we
treat very differently because I think
one valid criticism for a lot of these
Series so far is that they felt like
movies that were stretched to a little
bit longer length and then chopped up
weird where no single episode is
necessarily what you call a good episode
of Television like they have it has to
all fit together yeah so like this is
maybe an opportunity I think jihook did
a great job of being like we can have
Standalone episodes we can kind of play
around with the format a little bit so
this makes me think that they're
recognizing yeah if we want to tell
certain kind of story we'll do it in a
movie a different kind of story doing on
a TV show something we were saying
before in the meeting today was that you
know dare level the series on Netflix
was great and it was awesome yeah and it
worked so well and it felt real and like
the hallway scene is incredible right
but if you're watching a movie and that
hallway fight sequence happens you might
think it's incredible but you might be
like that's it that's what you got like
I want to see him in the [ __ ] you know
teasing him getting to the suit was like
a fun thing yeah for sure like get to
the suit yeah oh I'm always that way in
those movies I know that makes me a
little basic but I'm like put the suit
up let's make it a good one quit putting
a hoodie on over your head it's what we
loved about Spiderman Spiderman
homecoming right
he's got the powers no Origins I mean
that's what those Spiderman man they
really God bless you we're going to come
back to that we're going to come back to
that but um yeah so like uh in d23 is
when Kevin feige mentioned converting it
from a series to a film well famously in
Comic Con it wasn't on the Slate right
I'm sure Kevin Went backstage like yeah
we killed we killed Comic-Con we did it
we made the rocket shot that was great
check this phone there's like a text
from Don Cheadle he's like yeah yeah
blasters hitting him on the company
slack like hey okay we're over here in
the armor Wars offices and the lights
are off
they're replacing our placards with
something that says iron heart I don't
know well and I think we got to Circle
back to like what this means about
ironheart now does that mean obviously
people are going to be in Mech suits in
Iron Heart at least one person needs to
show us we need to see somebody in a
signature outfit yeah does that mean
like maybe she's gonna spend more time
out of the costume than him it's just
one person person versus an arm Awards
is going to be a lot of students so
that's why I'm like the level of combat
right like she might be more like using
her suit but she's just fighting Anthony
Ramos's like normal looking dude with
magic right versus like yeah a big
spacer we saw the images of her that
were leaked I guess on uh from set in
her practical suit and I was like oh
okay yeah it's just gonna be a lot of
ground work that's not not as much sky
and maybe that was low-key one of the
reasons they wouldn't let her leave
wakanda with the vibranium yeah uh this
thing this thing flies too fast
we can only afford two minutes of post
credits uh we can't have uh a five
minute scroll so we gotta eliminate all
those animators that do the effects of
the effects company if she's like at the
end of wakanda forever she's starting to
leave with a suit and then like
k-e-v-i-n comes in he's like
oh my God not for your show she's like
could you imagine how much that would
tarnished that movie is it's like it
would be like what you know like there's
there's a few I can't think of them now
but like famous movies that are like 98
wonderful and then just have such record
scratch moments and then I know there's
some good examples put them in the chat
if you got them super hey Super Chat up
to me because I got some self-help books
for you yeah you should have never
killed the shark game yeah and again a
reminder these these self-help books is
part of the Redemption are very good oh
the best example sorry of this is uh
First Blood which is you know but it's
the right no means a masterpiece but
it's a movie everybody loves in the
original version of it rainbow kills
himself he dies yeah now there's 17
Rambo sequels so obviously financially
it was it didn't stick
the one thing that can't hit
open this beach
capitalism uh but I think like this is
really intriguing and like we are not
the biggest
iron Wars aficionados necessarily I
haven't read it
yeah I was so confused when you said it
I keep I keep mixing
words in my brain so my glass house just
shattered by me throwing a stone correct
thing I like the real time it's better
you correct me than like the viewer yeah
well they can't they don't have
computers that's oh wow how are they
watching they're watching us on our
Times Square billboard
most of our viewership comes from that
billboard
um but uh yeah they they kept the same
writer when this was converted so it
doesn't have a director attached to it
this is presumably gonna film next year
for release 2024 kind of the back end of
phase five I believe now can I can I put
a little Theory bomb in here I know we
don't like to go too bro there's going
to be a big announcement about a plot
line in this movie because right now as
it is armor Wars we've known Roadie for
I mean the character we've known for 13
years since the beginning of the MCU as
we know Don Cheadle is roadie we've
known for 11 years or 12 years
I feel like they're gonna have to either
announce some castings that are pretty
like not that don't you know is a movie
star but there are very few actual if
you ask anyone real movie stars out
there anymore in general they can carry
a movie usually it's this especially
with MCU movies it's the characters
right so I feel like there's going to be
some huge do you think this is like a
low-key uh like they slip a Hulk in
there they slip a uh one of the other
big characters is gonna show
kind of like a back door kind of the way
uh you know Civil War wasn't really
Captain America movie I feel like the
armor Wars are gonna happen but I feel
like what the events around them and
who's fighting in those armor Wars are
there's gonna be some huge casts yeah
well and the things leading up to this
that we feel like we know roady's
showing up in secret Invasion right
right and so like that's obviously going
to set up some of this plot and then in
between now and then we're also getting
new world order yes that feels like of a
similar thread Thunderbolts might also
be in that line we kind of have multiple
threads of the MCU going now at the end
of Thunder bolts uh roady's gonna turn
to the camera and say begun the armor
Wars have ah or what if this what if
armor Wars is where the Young Avengers
are introduced or or some sort of other
team what if the armor Wars is where the
new team up is and maybe they don't tell
you who's going to be in it they just
tease this is the new team like there's
a line of like half of life oh and I've
dealt with Avengers before yeah I've
never seen a group like this and Roadie
is almost the Nick Fury yeah of this
group possibly Gallagher the comedian
ghost
what what he's one of the he's one of
the new friends
comedian no he's the comedian ghost yeah
I mean great if they recast ghost but
with galago God God needed a watermelon
Smasher and he ordered what he dialed
one up
oh sorry Dash oh I know Dash was a huge
Gallery
Gallagher too his brother rest in power
wow
um okay yeah and so and kimbreak has
even said that secret Invasion will tie
in directly to armor Wars
um do you how do you think that might
connect otherwise we know Don cheadle's
right here in both how do we think
secret Invasion could connect to armor
Wars oh well if there is a scroll who's
embedded in the government and it's
somehow feeding stealing vibrating I'm
vibrating them and feeding it to either
a a militant group of Scrolls feeding
into Liberia feeding it somewhere else
like that's that's how I could see armor
Wars leading or secret invasionally into
armor Wars I think this like new world
order thing is very important yeah
whatever this new world order is like
that's going to be a big deal I agree I
think armor Wars is going to be playing
kind of how like Thor movies play like
Thor Ragnarok and Thor it's kind of like
an offshoot of what the actual timeline
is going to be so I think that's going
to be directly connected to New World
Order then it is going to be to secret
uh Secret Wars I think it's gonna be
like whatever happens in armor Wars
connects to New World Order then to
Secret Wars yeah and like that new world
order has the potential to be a Civil
War style yeah right kind of like
balancing the sides bringing them all
together who is Cap going to side with
him
the key of the MCU for sure uh Neymar
was also quoted in this podcast as
saying they wanted they needed the
bigger stage of a film to uh talk about
the Fallout of Stark technology right or
the legacy of Tony Stark and his
technology which is interesting we'll
tie in teasing later Tommy's mandatory
fund kind of plays on this idea as well
later in the end of the episode but like
I love this idea that like the shadow of
Tony Stark for years and years and years
through the MCU continues to exist even
without Robert Downey Jr what power
what power I agree I mean seriously like
that create I mean that is a I mean what
a translation from comic book to screen
where you have a character that has
influence in movies and storylines
beyond their characters on screen depth
that is permanent yeah well when you're
a character that has so much to leave
behind I feel like uh Captain America
also does but it's a physically it's
just a shield where Iron Man has an
entire Stark Industries and all of the
stuff that come with it so it's just
like people are going to find those
pieces and keep making off of that
through the future you only get one
Shield but you got a million a million
Tony Stark things I I agree we we miss
him three thousand speaking of three
thousand Brandon and I will show full
butt over 2000.
Brandon promised his butt yesterday
and we'll surrender his butt for three
thousand surrender thy butt
break room break room after dark we'll
be launching that later uh but uh oh
we're gonna shout out a couple other
super chats here Bucky Barnes ATL we we
see you
is always swooping in from our neighbors
to the north yeah yeah but he said Zach
should get a film juice tattoo how dare
you invoke his name oh come on don't
even say his name the name makes me
Furious also you can't get a tattoo of a
garbage can on you can you wow you could
submit it to Ink box uh if you're just
joining the show today's the big ink box
oh yeah maybe I will ask inkbox to give
me a trash can tattoo we remember
remember my Arch enemies every time I
look down at like Muslims it could
happen ink box has been sponsoring uh
break room all week long they sponsor
our wakanda forever breakdown as well uh
and they make these premium temporary
tattoos I actually have one so this guy
I think a great thing about inkbox this
guy is like almost three weeks old wow
uh but the nice thing is like you just
kind of slowly fades it doesn't like it
patchy or scaly or anything like that
he'll be gone in another couple days
does he plead for for life
it's like uh yeah Back to the Future
um but your kids are gonna love it they
have thousands of tattoos you can pick
from all kinds of artists collaborations
they have the this great website
um but the thing we've been talking
about is they have a custom maker so you
can design any tattoo you like they'll
print they'll make it they'll ship it to
you you could test out a tattoo you
really want to get you can make
something for an event or to honor a
friend whatever you want
um there's still time to freak your
family out for Thanksgiving it's still
time freaky Thanksgiving oh
uh we uh we got some custom ones made
inspired by break room catchphrases
personal hobby horses whatever uh and uh
over the last three days we've been
doing the chat and I won
and I will be receiving a Gucci to muchi
tattoo designed by Tommy uh I will be
putting it on as a trim stamp at the end
of the show we're not forcing him to do
that uh he said he would do it
so Pony up the dough not to make a
second horse reference in 30 seconds
I'll put one on too but you know what
we're we're only 10 of the way there so
I have no family you know let's chat uh
to beat a dead horse I'll do another
night we gotta say save it save it
but uh so stick around to the end of the
episode when I will be uh getting my
Gucci to moochi
very close to both my Gucci and my no
you did you did promise that I could use
my tongue to it to uh prep the area
also Zach always a crosstalk to
Thanksgiving
my in-laws
to get your own egg Box Tattoo click the
link in the video description or head to
inkbox.com and use code new rockstars to
get 25 percent off your entire order no
minimum order requirement but you can
only use that code once so get a bunch
of them
that's good through the end of the year
again that's clicking the link in the
description or go to inkbox.com and use
code new rockstars for 25 off and we've
said this before but I will command them
because like each uh tattoo comes like
individually sealed in like an [ __ ]
packaging so if you want to order a
bunch you can hang on to them and use
them throughout the year they're very
well sealed very hard to say yeah this
is definitely uh very fun I I can't wait
to go I will be going Xbox I'm saying
like I put that little skateboarding
frog on my arm he's gone now because I
shot a commercial not to brag but I was
in a pool for four hours
skated off my arm uh but uh but uh but
yeah you know I was getting compliments
from people they were like did you get
that tattooed on your arm for real and I
was like yeah in jail okay
um moving on to some other headlines uh
okay this is the big one this just broke
maybe like two hours years ago yes
variety announced that Sony and Amazon
have struck a deal to make multiple
live-action shows based on Marvel
characters controlled by Sony so these
are all spumcy or kind of spider-verse
characters uh multiple shows now they've
only announced the specific details of
one and that's going to be a show called
Silk spider Society silk being a
character from the comics uh
korean-american woman who had spider
powers uh it's gonna be Show run by
Angela Kang who worked on Walking Dead
what things some people are gonna get
stabbed you're gonna see the blood oh my
God maybe on Amazon on Amazon that's
going to be I mean our live-actions oh
my God we might get it because of that
Angela Kang is currently the is the
co-creator but is I think leaving the
shortening position of the Daryl Dixon
spin-off oh don't you do this show which
I you know have read up and I got to ask
Jessica do you are you familiar with
silk the uh I read her uh in oh my gosh
I read her a long time ago when she was
working with Shang Chi and it's a real
and it's a really good run and I'm so
sorry it was during oh my gosh you
better answer it no no oh look look it
up because it's really good it's a
really great run where they have every
superhero in the Marvel cinemat or the
Marvel universe that are uh Asian
Americans and it was all of them
fighting together and it's so fun and
Cindy moon was my favorite was there a
Jubilation Lee I wish she's uh I think
there was and I hope and honestly I
probably blocked it out of there look at
me I I nailed the first one this is what
I think is interesting about Cindy Moon
okay so she gets bitten by the same
spider yeah as Peter Parker same spider
she's six one six which I thought was
very interesting she exists in the same
world as was she just like hanging out
in that lab and then like
she goes on like another field trip to
the lab which like stop bringing kids
are getting dipped her it dies
afterwards Peter never reported back
yeah
no one knows that people are getting bit
by radioactives trying to keep it hidden
but we were saying like fake news
there's a there's a lot there's a lot to
think about here we know executive
producers are going to be Lord and
Miller makers of the spider-verse films
in addition to the Lego movies and lots
of other great stuff uh so that's pretty
cool Amazon at least recently is a
really great track record with superhero
stuff we all love the boys I like their
animated stuff and that's the thing is
like Invincible is great and even the
boy spin-off series that was animated is
really good and they're like d d ones
are really good and they're so gory
because it's by the same people that do
Invincible it's perfect so I am a little
nervous about a live action version
because the boys is the top tier can I
go can I go Machiavellian movie Mogul
mode on you guys whoa yeah go ahead I
don't know that this is our new segment
Machiavellian movie 4m's uh yeah it's
the Forum Society uh not to be confused
with 3m who makes wonderful camera films
uh now and I believe white out eight I
believe okay I found it I think
Disney is a big fan of this deal because
they're going to let Amazon beta test a
little more aggressive TV content for
Marvel characters and then you know
who's going to start showing up we're
gonna see like Deadpool swing into one
of these shows they're gonna be like let
me load your character and then we just
slowly dance a few of them on over to
Disney Plus in the end I think that I
think you might see this as like wow
Sony kind of you know skirting Disney
who they kind of need for these
Spider-Man main Spider-Man movies I
don't think so I think Disney's got a
little hand in the pot I like that we've
been talking about you know Amazon
through the bank and rings of power they
do have a lot of money I think it brings
up power if you like to eat in like it's
a gorgeous show this is a great quote
from the talk of the state that was like
yes we had a lot of offers they offered
us by far the most money yeah yeah huge
sets great news yeah we don't know
obviously the boys has a high budget
it's probably a similar budget it's
higher I don't know and I don't know how
it Compares well
oh yeah obviously but like I don't know
how the boy's budget Compares yeah
Marvel's right uh Disney plus series it
feels like similar well the boy's
turnaround time is a lot shorter it's
like they they write it and then they
immediately shoot it and I don't know
why they do that because now they're on
like a fourth season so it's like oh I
think you can take your time you've got
like four seasons
so it's like yeah also yes uh Bruce
Wayne in the chat said at agents of
Atlas that's the comic book series that
has Cindy Moon and a lot of Asian
Americans
it's really fun we're saying there's a
lot of fun details here and hopefully we
get more coming out sometime soon I mean
obviously we don't have other than
Angela King being a part of this project
we don't have any casting or no anything
or we don't know release dates either
you just know that this deal was signed
but uh part of the article just kind of
threw off that Sony has the rights to
900 Marvel characters yes and these are
ones that I'm gonna name them all now
for you
[Laughter]
this includes you know Aunt May Uncle
Ben like every basement it's all their
iteration every every character that's
ever appeared in a Spider-Man comic that
is not Wolverine or fantastic or
whatever I'm sure they can grab one and
make that's the that's the heart of it
all is grabbing one and making a great
story for that character like uh example
a no more no one really is like yeah you
read the comics you're like yeah this
guy's all right but you had to make him
into something so likable and so great
this show is pre-taped so I want our
editors to remember no it's live it's
live I think we should do a video about
the most juicy Sony characters that
they've had to put on screen and put it
on channel
um well and you know one thing my boy
that's very funny
we were just talking about how Marvel
seems to be viewing the Disney plus
series as a way to like launch new
characters give them origin stories and
then maybe push them to the movies so
Sony is the biggest Hollywood studio
that does not have a streaming service
right right and so this makes a lot of
sense Amazon though they own MGM they
don't really have a studio so it's a
nice pairing a big streaming service
they own MGM as well
if you read the Variety article
this is actually going to premiere on
MGM plus which is going to be the Sony
streaming service
domestically in the US globally it will
appear on Prime video at the same time
and then I think like I'm not sure I I
imagine after a certain amount of days
it'll then roll over to Amazon but they
are releasing this series specifically
and supposedly the other one's on the
new MGM plus streaming app they didn't
have so many right now yes which will
probably be House of Gucci this movie
all the James Bond films but like house
party it makes a lot of sense looking
back if Sony did have a big Netflix
Disney plus style streaming service some
of these spumcy spin-off projects that
are in development what they've made
with morbius or Craven the hunter are
some of these I I hope Craven Hunter and
Madam Webb are gonna be awesome movies
but like with some of these have made
more sense as a streaming series you may
not get the star power that are in those
movies first but who knows it's quite a
little Kevin Bacon was in the following
for two seasons you can get anybody on
TV that's your barometer I love it
that's your big name Kevin Bacon famous
for doing anything uh also desperate for
money after they're made on yes Kevin I
forgot he made off Kevin Bacon and
curious Cedric lost all their money to
Bernie Madoff and you know what the true
uh villain of the real life right there
yes okay uh anyways we're gonna come
back this is probably gonna be a story
we're gonna get more details out over
the next couple days and
um hopefully weeks um maybe we learned
some more series they have planned if
not we're going to speculate the [ __ ]
out of them tell you all the ones we
want to see oh
oh I could do one okay this is this is a
book from a man who's he's lived he's
died he's lived he's died he's lived he
died
I don't know do we rip here yeah let's
talk about it
he got shot into he got shot into Heaven
by Johnny Depp uh here we go okay uh
this book is called the vision prism how
to manage your personal well-being
through the many phases of your life
too many phases are we phasing through
that is beautiful that is and and phase
Marvel phases that makes sense Tommy you
had one yeah I actually picked up this
book it was really weird it was huge and
it was Heavy it was called from She-Hulk
to me Hulk my journey to defeat the
monster within oh yeah uh actually
what's funny is women's week says this
movie or this book is crazy
but Wired Magazine says
[Applause]
speaking speaking of Wire magazine Amy
Allison and a a Super Chat saying poor
B2 emo and I gotta say oh my God
apologies
has broken my heart and my soul there
were I can't live
Marva there were like five heartbreaking
moments the most recent episode of
Andorra if you're not watching that show
I don't then you're dead stay with him
just someone to hang out with him
somebody stay with that Droid I'm so
lonely I have nobody
took on my own cause Marvel
all right now I didn't finish uh the
She-Hulk to me Hulk uh has a little
blurb uh from Todd at the bottom that
says if I could bang this book I would
uh reminder we're getting Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special yeah over a
week
for tomorrow
November yeah so you can watch it all
November 25th Christmas my Christmas is
in December my Christmas is Christ's
actual birthday December 25th wow I
thought it wasn't actually Tommy you
know he was probably born in the summer
okay all right okay all right uh but
we're getting that later this month Zoe
Saldana is out there doing uh
promotional tour for her movie what's it
called from scratch or Netflix flick but
I didn't know she was coming out of the
movie yeah I think it it just it's
already out on me on Netflix but she's
been good pressed for that and so she's
getting asked a lot of Guardians
questions
um she gave a comment on Guardians three
uh which again is the second Marvel
movie coming out next year after Ant-Man
of the lost quantumania I think it's
dropping no I'm sorry it's not it's the
third the second one's the Marvels
oh there we go thank you John I'm not
ready yes yeah we get condominium
February Guardians in May and the
Marvels in July we used to be we used to
have blade in November yeah
so they're they're still kind of
wrapping that up she's just kind of
coming from shooting of Guardians three
so you're talking about like what that
process has been like she said it's it's
bittersweet after all these years of
complaining about that green makeup
which I saw another interview with her
she said she has to show up at 3am every
day on set and do five hours of makeup
every day Chris Pratt gets to roll in
and just put on a jacket yeah and they
airbrush some ABS on him yeah Google it
our God is an awesome God don't make it
out okay was like can I wear long
sleeves and gloves today James Gunn was
like
um but anyways she said though even
though that part of the process is a
pain certainly for her and for Karen
Gillen right and I guess Dave Batista as
well they all have to do so much makeup
but she said I find myself getting
nostalgic about it there's a lot of
melancholy there but they're also Pride
that we've achieved something great
James Gunn has written a beautiful story
that's making us emotional even as we
shoot it which is a sweet thing to hear
um she's always giving great quotes
about how like anytime she's in public
and like she sees like a father and
daughter be like those movies meant so
much to us right like it's like a nice
reminder of like painting yourself green
and swinging a sword or whatever can
have a big impact on the world you're a
very thoughtful actor I appreciate that
I think a lot of you know to speak as a
man on behalf of young women I think
they like the character too yeah you go
to Disney you see a lot of girls dressed
up as like you more and stuff she's very
popular yeah do you of all the
characters from The Guardians of the
Galaxy who's the most likely to keep
showing up I think it's going to be uh
mantis and Drax I think definitely yes
oh well like in storyline I was saying
those two okay in the real world I yeah
probably Drax and Chris Brown I would
say like nebula I feel like nebulous
someone you can just throw it and I
think she genuinely loves it she loves
it I also think I mean Groot and Rocket
both because they're animated so it's
pretty easy and it's a pretty easy on uh
Bradley Cooper but I had a bad feeling
that
it'll be really interesting to see
you know yeah James Gunn's done with the
Guardians franchise hell he's got to go
over there and make DC movies now
um like but it's such a great franchise
like do they new Guardians come on the
comics there's new Guardians all the
time yeah they get all that Stallone in
there even this combination of Guardians
was pretty much I'm I'm speaking uh
through my own glass house here I think
it was like a pretty new combination of
them it wasn't this many it's not the
traditional lineup and like we know
there's been a rumored Nova project for
a long time
Thor's just floating around in space now
like he could be in there for a while
yeah I see three of those giant trees
hit the one in the middle oh
so uh we're excited and again a little
over a week we'll have the holiday
special who knows what that's going to
be about we're really excited for that I
mean we know what it's going to be about
but we don't know the impact it's gonna
it's gonna be about the greatest movie
star in the world
Kevin Bacon oh okay that's true
Santa Claus who has we already
reiterated in this episode needs the
money I don't think he does any more
does he
maybe maybe he's got a gambling problem
do you Kevin call in oh Kevin Bacon come
on the break room no no in honor of his
appearance in the holiday special maybe
we need to do a break room Six Degrees
of Kevin Bacon yes
[Music]
um that's a good mandatory fun put a pin
in it guys when we air this episode
[Applause]
it's not that time yet John now we're
doing the graphic unrequested oh wow
yeah this is coming what's happening uh
for mandatory fun Graphics lasting
longer than two hours consult your
physician and we're gonna we're gonna
come back to some Amy Adams uh DC news
um some interesting hinting news about
the Wonder Man series that's coming up
first we want to thank our friends at
aspiration that helped bring break room
to you that's right because when it
comes to climate action your money is
power and with aspiration a new kind of
change is in your pocket simply by
moving your money to aspiration you're
giving your deposits a cleaner Greener
meaner home I added aspiration is a
climate friendly alternative for your
money aspiration lets you plant a tree
by rounding up every swipe of your debit
card oh nachos at the movie theater
that's a tree ooh gasoline that's a
treat lady of the night in Las Vegas
that's a treat
they have square spots
listen aspiration has already funded the
planting of over 100 million trees
that's 50 million hammocks folks and
they're on their way to funding the
planting of one billion trees by 2030.
maybe that's too many maybe the trees
take over and they take back the land oh
no best of all there's no credit check
with aspiration no overdraft fees and
with aspiration you just pay what you
think is fair even if that's zilch not a
zero because money shouldn't stand in
the way of you doing the right thing
make your dollars make a difference for
once open an aspiration account at
aspiration.com tree that's t-r-e-e help
save the planet with your aspiration
debit card open your account at
aspiration.com tree today aspiration.com
tree terms and conditions apply
aspiration is not a bank deposits or
FDIC insured up to two million dollars
per capacitor hell yeah nice work uh
thank you to aspiration for sponsoring
the show all week long real quick we
wanted to talk about Adam Barnhart I
think I'm pronouncing his name right I
had a tweet this week
um he's from comicbook.com that uh
hinted that the Wonder Man series which
we know is cast Yaya yeah I'm doing my
teen
um as the titular man of Wonder uh is
going to be longer than six episodes
yeah well so basically it was a deadline
uh article that said they were casting
uh for a female lead female protagonist
uh Beyond obviously besides one internet
and then Wonder man's agent which I
think had been rumored to be Bob Odin
correct just some rumors flying around
yeah obviously maybe that's not signed
sealed and delivered and the agent's
role will be a villainous one and then I
said the series is expected to be six
episodes and and Adam just kind of
comments on top possibly more than six
so you know who knows as a refresher all
the MCU series with the exception of
She-Hulk have been six episodes I
believe no no was there a seven was
there a seven in one Division One
Division was seven was six
just those two
yeah six
um Miss Marvel Falcon Winter Soldier
Echo Knight they were all six Echo has
the 1090 order that FX used to give out
100 episodes I mean I'd watch it uh but
uh so that's interesting maybe that
hints at
um it being a more similar to She-Hulk
more of a comedic angle I mean
wonderman's wonderment wonderman's kind
of like a little more comedic I think
just in general a little more
irreverence do you see him doing comedy
Yaya has not done any comedy uh it
doesn't mean he's not good but it is all
clowning
hope this show is like super meta and
it's like he's making a movie about The
Avengers or something but then he also
has Paris so it's easier on the FX
Department they're like well yeah you
just fly we don't have the green screen
yeah and and you know Wonder Man's
powers are can kind of just be like
punching through walls and stuff like
that right he he doesn't it's not like
Vision or Captain Marvel or something
like that where he needs to fly into
space and shoot lasers or whatever
um but I'm I'm interested we again we're
just getting a little tidbits about this
this is not next year but the year after
very far out um or farther but uh so
anyways we'll we'll monitor that and
then Amy Adams of uh dear Evan Hansen
and what else hillbilly
Tommy loves to put their their most
famous
role he goes IMDb and goes to the last
one I go to whatever that's the worst
moment also of a disenchanted which I
think comes out this week on Disney
Premiere or okay let's not name our good
credits that's okay uh but anyway she
was speaking to variety you're probably
doing press for disenchanted and they
they mentioned hey Henry Cavill is back
at Superman right showing up in the
post-credit scene of uh Black Adam uh
and she's like yeah isn't that exciting
and they kind of asked her like what do
you think you might come back as Lois
Lane and she kind of gave the the pat
responsive they haven't spoken to me
about it if it's me great if it's
somebody else the role of Lois has been
filled by so many wonderful actresses in
the past so I'll support whatever
decision
they should do it like this Terry
Hatcher Terry Hatcher a lane Point film
where it's all the lowest Lanes meeting
up for once oh I'm like okay everybody
go watch Terry Hatcher and that James
Bond movie where I think her first name
is Paris holy hell
Terry Hatcher brought heat okay both his
lowest landing and all her roles she's
uh terrific actor also uh loves the
paddle pajama Playhouse just a few miles
uh west of of Los Angeles or east of Los
Angeles where uh some people live we
don't we're in Canada
I think we have another Redemption Tommy
we
do it's called finding the Roar and
Terror an introductory act a terrorist
guide for master thespians by Trevor
Slattery uh this is a book Finding the
Aurora and Terror I love this this is a
book for all of you who like to tread
the boards but don't want to go to war
okay make your viral videos from your
itty bitty Studios with Trevor Slattery
a two-time Academy Award attendee
just shows up Hollywood Reporter says no
no no no no no this ain't a good idea
fam cut that [ __ ] out right now variety
magazine says we kind of like it Fox
News says where was Trevor on January
6th doing the right thing
I'm putting the Roaring Terror a
beginner's guide to terrorism for master
thespians I wanted to watch read it no I
don't so I mean no no [ __ ] anybody
else Tommy did that off the Dome
it's a real book it's a real book yeah I
mean I know that he memorized yes I
memorized the whole book uh and then uh
real quick uh two last little bits of uh
headline on Twitter a quiet place day
one this is the spin-off that's gonna
star uh Lupita Nyong'o uh the oh I said
and but yeah well yeah that's what the
headline is uh the director of that
announced that stranger things breakout
star Joseph Quinn will join the film
Eddie I love it I can't have any more
bat-like creatures attacking my sweet
Joseph Quinn hands off if any if Joseph
Quinn goes down in a quiet place
[Laughter]
this is him and Lupita in a bathtub the
whole time it's just an erotic thing
that's not quite anymore uh the first
you're gonna attract the bat people the
first hour and 41 minutes is uh an
erotic Thriller in the last three
minutes the aliens pop up God we've had
so much sex in this tub did you hear
something else
Tommy's broken you broke down I'm gonna
pass out I just got light-headed and
then uh finally some some interesting
intriguing Quentin Tarantino news he he
did it he's doing a book tour right now
he's got a new book out and in an
interview with Elvis Mitchell uh he
announced that he's going to shoot an
eight episode TV series next year we
don't know what the series is where it's
gonna be you know anything else other
than any shooting an eight episode
series and it's definitely not a
superhero movie yeah interesting though
because in that article Elvis Mitchell a
friend of the show just kidding but I
met him once he was really nice come on
the show Elvis they asked uh he probably
would he's a good guy uh they asked uh
they asked Tarantino if he what you know
after his quote of I don't want to be a
Hired Hand what would you be interested
in bringing to the uh to the screen uh
from the comic book world and I think
it's kind of a safe answer for him
Sergeant Fury and his Howling Commandos
reunited with his old friend Sam Jackson
yeah you know reunited with his old
friend Neil McDonough you know reading
Diamond's old friend Kenneth Choi you
know uh I can't remember anyone else he
was a pretty good girl on those on those
Commandos it's not Tate Donovan but it's
someone yeah Diggs no
the Tay's annotates come on the show
yeah
um uh yeah interesting and he's been
attached to a uh
um oh what's the uh FX Cowboy series
that you love Justified Justified reboot
with um
four he did two episodes of CSI in 2005
in an episode of ER in 1995 yeah oh I I
think I think you guys are right on the
money though I don't want him to do an
original show I want them to give him an
existing show for a season maybe a show
that's not doing well maybe it's kind of
all over the place but let old buddy
Tarantino come in and take it away we
hear you loud and clear welcome to the
neighborhood starring Cedric the
Entertainer and Max Greenberg directed
by Tarantino oh my God my wife Cedric
how are you I love you you dropping the
volume on yourself
speaking of watching shut your eyes and
open your ears because we've been
reminding you for weeks now to check out
the second season of the hit show DC's
Batman the audio Adventures which is out
now on HBO Max this is incredible cast
including Rosario Dawson John Leguizamo
Bob Moynihan Christopher Parnell Seth
Meyers my favorite role personally
playing a basically the the conscience
of the audience as a like radio DJ
that's like why do we have uh food food
eating contest in Gotham City when there
are psychopaths running amok uh Tina
Thompson and Jeffrey Wright playing
Batman himself the show is full of Crime
full of humor in Batman Laura as I've
said before the Venn diagram of SNL and
Batman they mean right in the middle for
a sweet circle of fun for your ears
morning Hannah is the penguin is a top
performer for me all right I mean I
could go on and on just enjoy it okay
I've been I don't even want to finish it
because I've been just devouring it you
know just Savory bites that man the
audio Adventure season two out now on
HBO Max it's time for mandatory
oh there it is delish that's right the
segment for your eyes and ears and all
you hold dear hit the graphic again
we've already played the graphic out of
sequence twice so why don't we play the
graphic in sequence nice I hit it again
noise
all right now
we chopped it up about arm rewards a
little earlier but this is the season of
giving and hope and I have a huge
surprise for you and that is if you
haven't subscribed now I'm coming to
your house
subscribe and like okay like And
subscribe it's very easy now I knew this
chat would be financially impotent there
was no chance I was gonna get a tattoo
so that's fine we're comfortable but I'm
Gonna Give You mandatory fun anyway
because I got my three best friends in
the whole damn world here with me today
and we're gonna have a little fun a
little hope a little positivity now I
play a little prank on you guys what I'm
sorry I'm a little stinker sometimes I
asked you guys to tell me your favorite
MCU powered up suits not just because
I'm curious like a little kitty cat
nope because I have a cousin who
modifies cars and Suits
it's got a cousin documents the back
told family is talented yeah
be sure to stick around because uh the
tattoos are coming soon right now
how y'all do it oh my name is t Michael
Beck zibit and I'm gonna pimp your suit
see Michael back zip it that's right I'm
T Michael Bixby yeah Missy Lou I ain't
seen a finer face on a lady since I went
to Farrah Fawcett's funeral all right
now oh my God no
no no that open casket yeah it was a
wide open casket or at least it was for
me I don't know I cracked that thing
open like a box of Cracker Jacks and
there was a prize inside
for me will you Mr bexhive that's
inappropriate that's team Michael back
we're gonna pimp the suits Brandon you
chose the star boost yeah I do like the
star boost suit you kind of saw it in
Iron Man 3 it was very you had to clock
it this is a suit Towing design allows
him to go into space if you played The
Avengers game there was like one of the
only good things about that game was the
secrets where you get to fight I've been
to space in that too it's very fun I
preferred the brothels in that game that
you could visit now I don't think they
were Bronco maybe I just had a special
version of the game those are the perks
you get when your team
team a big exhibit yeah Brandon we
pimped your suit first things first we
put a Carly Rae jepsenal
just leave it alone oh
knock on your door just like before
we've had the loneliest time yes now I'm
coming back to you I'm coming back for
you what happened was
we reached the moon all right now the
second modification I made to pimp your
suit is I put a little viewing tablet
inside what's on that what is on that
photo
I got position I have what's called
dysgraphia Patterson kindergarten most
of the teachers thought I couldn't read
or write but it turns out my hand
muscles are just a little too weak I
don't know but this graphia look it up
it's there the next thing you've got is
a is a lady on a comic book I'll put a
viewfinder inside the thing so you can
read the original Jubilation Lee comic
book I don't think that's Jubilee that's
not her listen Jubilee tablet produce
that as the image results
the final modification I've made for
your suit because I know you love video
games I do because I got a retractable
link so no I I do like that authentic
from the game and that's how I made the
star boost suit peeps
I haven't seen a starburst like that
since I saw Naomi Judd blow wide open at
the Thanksgiving Day Parade in 1982 as
kind of the cocaine she was doing all
right
okay
yeah all right now that's what I was
thinking of I think you did the next one
we had Zach you chose rescue yes yes
from the movies now I like it it's it's
uh it's a Sleek design it's minimal for
a lady but we'll cram your cute body and
I love the color first thing first we
know no one wears a pair of khakis like
you said so we're replacing the metal
legs sensible pair of khakis now Zach I
know we don't have to go too deep into
your personal life but you have recently
become a father that's right so I found
a tactical baby
on the outside of the zoo right there
yeah
we can see your baby uh Xanadu anytime
day day or night don't know why he chose
that name very bizarre I think it's that
weird religion you subscribed to the
last thing a lot of y'all don't know
this but Zach loves fruit and I ain't
talking Roll-Ups and I ain't talking
Gummy Bears I'm talking fresh fruit yes
he's got a fruit podcast you can listen
uh where you get your podcast that's not
a plug-in sponsor us it's just a friend
lifting up another friend and don't we
not do that enough this time of year
people are ready to blow their goddamn
brains out oh my God
a retractable cider press wow
apple cider well you're flying your suit
around now last but not least
look at you the cutest little dumpling
that ever came to the county fair thank
you I will save that best relaxed
first things first we know that you are
you just got those wandering fingers
like a little little boy on hot cooling
pie shelf just getting things out of the
pack we turned your shield from task by
the way she shows tasks should have
mention that we turned your shield into
a fidget spinner oh thank you and it's a
branded opportunity it's a it's a
Spider-Man fidget spinner
check that out Sony you could buy that
AdSense that's right now next thing you
and I got similar tastes I know you like
those big titty anime girls
so I'll put a viewfinder in yours no
with a busty anime princess that's what
you did for mine that's right well well
sometimes team Michael Bechtel only has
enough bandwidth in his brain for one
semantic idea last but not least what
makes any outfit complete a game used
authentic Josh Allen Jersey right on top
you wear backwards like crisscross used
to I thought it made you want to jump
jump it was all about wearing jeans
backwards in the early 90s and I don't
know why my penis hurts because of those
jeans anyway I got a buckle on down the
trail right now but I hope you all had a
great day I had a great day with you
yeah this has been Pimp My Suits
Josh
Josh
we got drinks I mean it's it's like
paying my ride they didn't ask for those
popcorn machines
okay sorry I just saw my cousin running
out of here
I hope that wasn't too good this is a
busy single it's it's that time of the
show folks where we are going to stack
up here uh while we do we don't think a
lot of our super Chatters today uh TD
Johnson in a Super Chat Amiel said in a
Super Chat looking for those tattoos
Aaron storm thank you for super Chad
Bucky bartictio Miss Wayne oh he's
wiping that you gotta wipe that yeah
you should help him they give you this
uh which kind of cleans the area so the
tattoo of fixes better to it let me just
make sure you're putting it on the right
thank you yeah I won't be able to have
it be centered or anything you have to
put it right there I can take it okay
thank you Jessica okay okay so now so
this guy Gucci
do you want it to go which way do you
want to do go down so it's like Gucci to
muchi
like it was a like it was a butterfly or
whatever now what's your pain level
right now Zach oh it's zero oh they're
using a thick gauge you have to leave it
on for a minute yeah so I'll leave it on
there and then I'll show it off tomorrow
okay check it out he's been tatted it's
just that easy folks look at that it's
just you two could have Gucci to moochie
on your back 25 off with our code that's
right thank you to inkbox for doing this
to me if you're gonna leave thank you to
our trashy viewers who have saved me
from getting morbin time on my body you
just couldn't do it could you yeah
we're really close how much did you say
I said 300.
we're about 82 and a half bucks away
yeah we're not even close but thinking
uh this is me Senator Super Chat hoping
that okay Disney plus series is about
the midnight angels that could be
interesting oh yeah uh Haven sending in
a Super Chat uh lots of lots of folks
out there today David blonde sending a
Super Chat uh great stuff oh and we had
a poll who's armor who's pimped out
armor would you wear just running
I don't know there's a cyber press and a
tactical baby yarn by the way my brother
and I were looking into making tactical
baby gear a few years ago and then
someone else put the company out and
they're like multi-multi-millionaires
should have been you yeah my problem was
I love America too much now listen to me
okay we gotta do one more self-help book
Brandon you got one more oh I got
another one uh let's see this is not the
Dome uh oh there there was a great book
I saw called The Dark Elf on the Shelf
uh malekith's guide to a better life
after five minutes
uh here's another one too this one was
called The Love Bulova how to reject
your fake family and Learn To Love
Yourself
well you need your family no you reject
your fake family they lied to you damn I
need to read that book it was real to me
you guys came so close today but here's
what I'm gonna say I see some tattoos
over there there's a new rock star one
there's a more big time one if you guys
hit 300 tomorrow I'll put both on okay
you gotta hit 300. I ain't gonna change
because guess what I take my shirt off
in front of girls all the time oh okay
so I'm not gonna show them these weird
ass tattoos yeah he shot a commercial in
a pool folks yeah I don't know if you
know this I'm pool famous yeah he's a
working actor they call me the human
floaty
hmm I'm so buoyant I don't we'll get a
better nickname for you Tommy
um but thank you to everybody for
watching today we had a blast uh
tomorrow we'll wrap up the week we'll
have the best episode yes thank you my
cousin see Michael Beckers a bit uh he
was not cheap to get yeah yeah we
probably won't be able to do any more
bits this month oh well that's okay be
sure to like And subscribe to the video
there's tons of great videos coming out
today uh already we have an inside
Marvel out which is awesome uh Eric's
and or breakdown is out if you want to
cry again uh Jessica has it been coming
out today too that's about what's next
for Riri Williams oh that's right yes
tons of good stuff uh but we'll see you
all here tomorrow same time same place
uh latest games
[Music]